You know,
I don't really get upset about Oscar
snubs anymore because,
I mean it's the Oscars,
but I was a little sad to hear that Sean
Baker's the Florida project didn't make
the cut for best picture this year
because I think when it comes to the
Academy Awards,
the nominations really matter more than
who the eventual winner is.
It's always silly to pick the best
anything when it comes to art,
but with the nominations,
at least the 7,000
members of the academy get a chance to
highlight the field of diverse
transformative films.
If the Oscars won't highlight the
Florida project,
then I'm happy to because it's without a
doubt.
One of the best films of 2017 and
watching it for me was one of those
transporting experiences that I only get
a few times a year if at all.
His story is about a group of kids and
their parents who live in a budget motel
outside of Disney world in Florida,
that people who live in this community
are the economic margins.
Not quite homeless,
but not quite able to keep a permanent
roof over their heads either.
The struggles of living in this kind of
poverty give the film and undertone of
sadness,
but the genius of the Florida project is
that it tells its story from the
perspective of the children who can't
help but see their world as a playgroup.
Baker is pulling heavily from Hell
roaches,
little rascals,
a classic series of comedy,
Short films from the Twenties and
thirties that was groundbreaking in the
way that it showed the kids as well,
kids trying to capture the nuances of
their behavior and energy in a
naturalistic way like the Florida
project.
Rascals was set against economic
hardship,
the Great Depression,
these kids to work growing up in
poverty,
but the focus was never on that.
It was on the scrappy optimism of
childhood.
Now,
the Florida project has deeper ambitions
than rascals,
but that optimism,
the brightness of this point of view is
everything.
It keeps the subject matter from being
too overwhelming.
Something that can shut down our ability
to empathize and sympathize.
Sean Baker,
I think understand something really
critical about storytelling,
that we don't absorb things by looking
directly at them.
Often we see more clearly through
indirect means.
There's a lot that Baker and co writer,
Crispr,
Gosh want to say about the hidden
homeless in America,
but they don't just come right out and
say it or show it.
The reality of these troubled lives
exists in the peripheral vision of a
child's Day.
Baker in a cinematographer,
Alexis,
sob a keep the camera low.
Parents are often framed peanut style,
just a bunch of legs,
even when the kids aren't around,
they favor low angles so that adults
tower over the frames and through the
course of the film,
you remember what it's like to see the
world from such a low ankle.
You remember how big everything seemed
and how much sky there actually is
carefully building this perspective pays
off in a scene like this where you have
a key piece of information about these
people's lives,
which is that they struggle so much to
make their bills that they need the
assistance of a local church.
Food Bank make replace the scene again
from young Mooney's perspective and we
have to piece together what's really
happening here.
He doesn't want to show us the food
assistance itself.
He wants to show us how normal something
like that is to Moonee.
That's the devastating thing.
In fact,
all of the films,
most crushing moments are played from
the perspective of kids.
When Mooney's mother's starts
prostituting herself to make rent.
This is the way that the Florida project
shows us
be right back.
This is how the film talks to us.
Something is always seen through
something else.
The decaying edge lands outside.
Disneyworld are seen through the
colorful imagination of an adventurous
kid,
the promise of Disney world,
as seen through the poverty that
surrounds it.
The pain of living without work is seen
through the kindness of neighbors and
strangers and motel managers and Mooney
and her mother,
Haley,
the films two main characters are seeing
through each other.
In some ways.
Haley is a loving,
caring mother and others.
She's a delinquent,
selfish mother.
These are all things that we see and
learn through the way that Mooney acts
in Haley.
We see a Moonie that was child that grew
out of her innocence,
and we also see a Moonie that might be
this grace.
It's in the continuum of these two that
the film finds a way to express trues
that are larger than the movie itself,
for those living in the margins of late
capitalism tossed around by the wave of
the great recession,
Moonee and Halley are representative of
a cycle of hardship that can lock itself
into a family tree for decades.
Mothers like Haley bear some of the
responsibility for the situation,
but we bear some of the responsibility
too because as the film shows us,
mothers like Haley,
really just kids like Mooney and Mooney
is nothing but innocent.
It's a way of understanding the
individual and societal responsibilities
for poverty that only a film can achieve
and only a film with this kind of
discipline.
Now,
this doesn't mean that the Florida
project is trying to Trojan horse a sad
story to the viewer.
It's an incredibly joyous movie.
It's fun to watch like the little
rascals and the particular heartbreak we
feel doesn't end.
Can't exist without that joy.
Baker couldn't express one without
expressing the other because he
understands that they're part of the
same thing.
That's the kind of understanding,
and this is the kind of filmmaking
academy members should promote through
their nominations.
It's a shame they didn't,
but I guess I shouldn't mind about snubs
because I mean it's the Oscars.
Hey everybody.
Happy Wednesday.
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
verve.
If you don't know,
verve is a service that pulls together a
lot of great content channels like
rooster teeth,
Mondo,
crunchy roll funimation to watch all in
one place so you can see some of the
best enemy are definitely,
but they've also added a lot of new
channels like movie which hosts are
rotating roster of 30 indie movies,
which is something that I love.
One other show that I would personally
like to recommend is the director's
chair where director Robert Rodriguez
interviews other directors like Coppola,
George Miller,
Guillermo del Toro.
I've been looking for somewhere to watch
these episodes for so long,
so I'm thrilled that verve has it.
Now you can only watch that with
premium,
which gives you add free access to
everything,
all 13 channels and for a limited time
you can use the first link in the
description to get a 30 day free trial
of Verve,
so definitely try that out.
Oh,
and they have offline mode now too,
so you can watch all that awesome stuff
on the go without an Internet
connection,
which is pretty cool.
Thanks again guys.
I'll see you next time.